I
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to the to this session of piña de it's a
privilege to welcome Travis once more
and to have him talk about and talking
about a lot of interesting stuff to
building by data community so Travis
does not need any introduction but to
tell a few things Travis Olyphant is one
is as a inventor of numpy and he is one
of the original contributors of scifi
he's also the CEO and founder of one of
the cofounders of of continuum analytics
and and and he's along with Peter bang
I've started this pi data movement i
would say the series of my data
conferences and big thanks to him that
we are having this fight at a conference
at berlin 20 and ed yeah when he is
multifaceted multi-talented personality
and his team family man and and he has
been yeah he will tell more about
himself and his interest and the whole
Python community right now so give a big
hand and welcome Travis
alright thank you I appreciate that it's
really good to see you all here it's a
thrill to be in Germany in Berlin and to
see a growing PI data community I know
this is just the beginning especially
here where there's all kinds of activity
around data and hopefully using a lot of
Python along with other things that
you'll be doing I wanted to talk today
basically about kind of the community
and about how to how do we build a
stronger community and kind of aspects
of where it came from how we start why
it starts what motivates me what drives
me and then kind of what I understand
what drive some of the other folks were
part of this community as well I want to
spend a little bit of time talking about
numb focus non focus is really the
foundation that is behind and supports
and drives and receives if there are any
proceeds at all from a PI data
conference non focus receives those
proceeds it could help cut so continuum
basically backs the conference series we
make sure that it actually goes on and
there's funding to pay the venues and
pay the events and pay the people who
are involved Leah actually works for
continuum but we donate her time
entirely too numb focus so she can spend
her entire time community organizing
running the PI to the conference series
and none focus exists as a us 501 c 3
charity it's a public spirit in the USA
its purpose is to support world-class
innovative open source scientific
software really to enable reproducible
research open access to research it kind
of came out of realizing that I'll talk
a little bit more about where numpy and
unfocused came from but numpy sci-fi
matplotlib ipython pandas a lot of these
work could have happened by dedicated
individuals who spend a lot of time
doing it and then they there's a gap
there's a gap of sustainability that
ends up existing where there's all this
work and all this thing that can be done
but nobody really supporting it there's
some companies out there that are
benefiting from it but not necessarily
supporting it and so we wanted to create
numb focus as a central point of
cooperation between people who otherwise
even might compete some of the things we
do in um focus the activities that go on
and these activities really are as broad
as the people to get involved with non
pocus and it's
its core we're here to support the numpy
syfy pandas the software but also the
activities around the software and
community building around those software
so some of these activities the women in
science technology events this is a
fantastic program that's gotten started
Leah's done a great job of organized
with many others in the community should
really try to increase diversity we'll
talk about some of the issues that exist
in our community and it's definitely one
of them this is one of the activities we
do just funding them offering
scholarships to women and other
minorities to come to hide at events and
sci-fi events we have the John Hunter
technical fellowship grant programs to
loosely organized committee communities
just money to for sprints and codes and
and helping people get together and
paper drinks and pay for food this is
this is what num focus its purposes is
to really create legal foundation and
organization to promote things fiscal
scholarship this fiscal sponsorship and
legal protection ownership of community
websites things like petty org numpy org
Astro pie currently if you have a dot
org or add a 0 or a dot-com that you
that is a community site really and
should be kind of organized under the
auspices of a community organization um
focus is there to help I want to talk
about a few a couple of the programs and
um focus is involved with that I think
are really exciting one is this women in
science technology program which thanks
to JPMorgan they made a significant
donation to numb focus in order to warm
help promote more women in science and
technology so what that does is provide
funds we can pay for people to come to
the conference and attend and there's
been tremendous volunteer work from many
many professional women in the science
technology either scientists themselves
or professional programmers who come to
an event and teach typically younger
women just programming it so excited
about getting to the community it
there's many books out there about how
do you really increase diversity and get
more women involved in it at the core is
helping people feel welcome and having a
group that they can identify with its
it's hard to feel lonely and there's
many people who can talk about that much
better than I can but what I understand
and listening to their their challenges
it's hard to fill your you're lonely and
you kind of need to have speed
round two who supports you is that's the
purpose of women science technology
events is to really get more people
together we have a fantastic event this
picture is at facebook facebook hosted
last PI data event and together with
some of the funds that none focus
provide be able to invite 60 with high
school girls from the Silicon Valley
area and had about ten panelists we're
just phenomenal I got it I got a chance
to peek in because of course I don't
really participate in these events but I
get a chance to peek in and just see the
activity that's happening it's
phenomenal this energy is exactly the
kind of thing that a Community
Foundation and organizing together can
really promote and help and i look
forward to increasing the diversity at
events like PI data where we get to the
point where it's more like fifty percent
of the attendees are but currently our
minority the other significant activity
that we promote and JP Morgan has helped
fund this is the John Hunter technical
fellowship the idea for the this
technical fellowship really came from
recognizing that people spend they delay
their PhDs it lay their postdocs to
basically right open source software
that benefits the community so we said
why don't we just tackle that head on
and help if let's offer grant programs
as offer a fellowship to actually fund a
PhD student or a postdoc who is active
in the open source community wants to
spend some time contributing just give
them money well both for them and for
their mentor because it really it really
takes both my view of that is that a
mentor should be able to handle roughly
about five or six of these so they see
the money to the mentor who should be
about a fifth of what they need to live
for a year right what their manual
salary is that's the kind of money we're
talking about when you do a grant to a
technical fellowship you give it to both
the the person doing the code and the
mentor so they can significantly spend
time helping them both improve their
skills as well as contribute
significantly to the community so this
is a new program we fortunately were
just able to reward our 1st numm focus
technical fellowship to olga botvinnik
UC san diego i wish we had more funds
have been fantastic if we could have
ordered three there were many many
wonderful proposals to honorable
mentions came from Damon or Damian
bean and Connie Gao I would have loved
we took the whole board the committee
would have loved to fund all of them but
we don't have the money so you know
there's plenty of good work to do if
sponsorships come to numb focus and one
of the ways now focus is funded is
actually by the PI data events if we get
sponsors to PI data if there is actually
money left over and it will it will be
be left over only up there are sponsors
to the event then that money goes
directly to numb focus to fund these
sorts of things so it's named after John
Hunter who was one of the first board
members an initial board member of numb
focus along with myself and Toronto
Perez and Harry greenfield and Joe Jared
Millman unfortunately passed away in
2012 tragically we've named the
technical fellowship after him he's also
the author of matplotlib many of you
know that we all owe him a great debt I
mean it was family a great debt for the
time he spent in helping our community
and so we do try to give back to him
there's a place you can donate to his to
that his widow and his three children
all right so numb focused uh what what
happens to the money donated well it's
whatever the community that is it gets
involved with them focus sees to promote
its really a community run organization
but the kinds of things that we've
already seen a need for and try to
promote things like coding Sprint's just
buying food and travel so people get
together and talk and work together the
technical fellowships we talked about
equipment grants there's people who are
coding all day long who need a new
computer right and they either have to
buy it from their own funds or maybe we
can help support that conference
attendees to students so people are just
started getting started they need funds
to go to conferences they need funds to
go to PI data to excite to scifi other
of these events where they can learn and
grow and progress so we offer those
diversity scholarships as well as those
student scholarships and then you know
just creating tools and helping pay for
the fees for continuous integration for
software engineering tools pay for
repositories pay for bandwidth paper
time a lot of time that can be donated
to directly by the providers that give
it and that's fantastic if we really
exsist allowing the tools to be created
documentation developments that's one of
the things that always lags behind be
really difficult and so maybe hiring
people and helping the helping
excited and actually paying for this
documentation development web page
hosting the list goes on and on you can
imagine get involved with numb focus you
can be a part of what how that happens
it's a we have European directors we
have us directors it's a worldwide
organization so here is we support the
psf code of conduct because we're
affiliated with psf the affiliation is
is loose at the moment a lot of I'm
currently now I step down from the board
of numb focus and I became an advisor
said I'm focused the current board is
actually governed by nine these these
individuals there who deserve our
respect and support we all and then I
fortunately I'm also i'm working on the
psf board the board of the python
software foundation i'm serving the term
there currently and so I'm anxious to
make a real connection between the psf
and I'm focus so that we can both of
those communities can support each other
and while I've been here I've just been
aware of some of the European activities
European Python society they repeat the
European Python organization which are
fantastic organizations that also
contribute to the base language that the
num focus one of the base languages and
um focus supports num focus actually has
its vision all open accessible science
so we also support things like our we're
okay with Julia were really we're not
language-specific where language
agnostic and try to promote any kind of
open and accessible data science and
science engineering we have an open ship
member open membership model you want to
become a part of it I'm focused you just
send your name your email and country
where you live to Julia or to none poker
or or to the mailing group num pocus and
you're in and he'll be a member and then
you can participate in the conversations
the google group is an open may enlist
you can go and participate the
conversations and join so why didn't
unfocus number goes exists basically
because we found a continuum we wanted
to create a place where companies and
other community members could come
together even if they did compete with
each other outside of that organization
so we want to work together to fund it's
bigger than any one person bigger than
any one organizations who wanted to have
a place worth of some cooperation and
collaboration could take place and have
an independent board governance so
there's been a lot of significant both
personal and company contributions in
order to get numb focus off the ground
get the
did a series conference a cop ID that
conference series going it doesn't
happen just by magic it happens because
somebody cares and people push to make
it happen so a little context and
actually Julie steel sitting right here
on the front row once you stand up
Juliet one could say hi she actually
works for a she's moved from O'Reilly
now but she was participating and really
helped it was fantastic as we as Peter
and I started to reach out and say how
do we organize a community around data
and Python Julie was very very helpful
and pulled in her colleague & dunvale
and others and we were able to get a
hold of Google and they provided us
their headquarters so we could actually
have the first patented workshop at
Google headquarters in a spring of 2012
West McKinney came of course the author
of pandas who's done so much for
bringing that technology to the world
and so you know some photos in that
first tight end in a workshop actually
Peter Wang had a great talk about
community related to community building
in the last Silicon Valley and so I'm
borrowing a few of his slides you can go
and see his full talk for the for the
full impact of this of this event one of
the things that happen to that in that
event it was actually the birthplace of
content anaconda because we were we de
was there and we just for a few for a
day actually came and poked in and he's
always been supportive of the scientific
and data community in Python and he kind
of poked in to see what's going on and
you know we had a chance to talk to him
about you know packaging problem is
really is really still with us and it
really drives problems for especially
for our community with a lot of binary
dependencies and you know he was
basically empathetic but but not
particularly interested in sort of
driving a solution so he was sort of
like a go ahead now he all you know
since I think he took it to heart and
actually did support after this event
the Python packaging Authority kind of
kind of grew out and some of the other
entity and the other energy inside the
Python community existed but we went
ahead and said great we'll do it and we
created Conda an anaconda and created a
solution that would solve our problem
and I think it's a pretty it's a pretty
decent solution and it's open source
needs if you have an issue with it if
you have ways you see if you'll be
better please join that community and
spend a pull request and jump in so the
first two years of PI data PI data that
without 2012 event
happened then we've had a fight at a
conference a full conference that of a
workshop that fall in New York City and
then a pilot event right after PyCon in
parts 2013 in july two thousand thirteen
you can basically see a trend here the
number of ents is growing and as the
community has really responded to this
data python event and this concept it's
really been nice to see the community
responding and the other reason all of
these events have been able to happen is
because of community members volunteers
have gotten together and said okay we'll
help will help with program with review
will help with organizing in our city
and then some sponsors have actually
stepped up as well and provided venue
space provided hosting you know we're a
small company there's no way we could we
could host all these events and promote
all these events they do cost they are
risky there is sometimes they lose money
so it is not it's definitely not a it's
not necessary kievan that's a shall we
say so it really helps when when
somebody who donates the venue an event
my PI data really starts before just
this conference and this organization
that tried to that tries to bring back
energy into the community really the
first 20 years and you go all the way
back to the matrix object 1994 which is
Jim Fulton's when Python first came out
Python one point 0 came out in 1994 and
Jim poulton had this tiny little Python
only matrix object that he provides he
sent out to the list and said here's my
representation and from that that kind
of sparked a lot of interest curiosity
fact there's nothing like getting more
people to contribute than to put out
code you don't like you know put out
code and then have a thick skin and be
willing for people to say it sucks and
it's actually really motivating to
people for some reason they see oh
that's good Co but it really sucks or
make it better and then they go and they
put a pull request they improve it so
you know a little bit maybe a little bit
of a psychology there don't be afraid to
get your stuff out there if you have a
good idea if you don't if it's not a
good idea it'll die it will and that's
fine sometimes that it's part of
learning and it's part of the process by
which the whole community grows and
evolves so it's important to khatik
contributing even though the idea
doesn't survive because that matrix
topic really led to numeric and numeric
led the number Ray
and those two together and in America
also led to scifi which started as multi
pack in at 95 in 2001 was organized at
Syfy it led to ipython matplotlib simp I
numpy scikit-learn panis all those
things basically grew out of that effort
because it was a real need and it was a
real problem so it's been around for
really 20 years this whole community and
it's been abstract very it's been very
organic it's an emergent phenomena which
is fantastic and I think one of the
strengths is a emergent phenomena is to
not have sort of sort of top-down
control over something but allow it to
kind of grow and emerge however there
are principles that will allow that
community continue to exist so I wanted
to talk a little about these how do we
make sure that this community that we've
started will continue to thrive where do
we go from here how do we make sure that
we get we keep having more hard work
this is a slide again from Peter Wang
but I want to go in a little more detail
about what does this mean how do we do
this and what are some of the issues can
arise and also actually like to get some
responses from folks in here so is there
a microphone hopefully they can go
around I have a few slides coming up
where I'm going to ask you for answers
to some of these questions that I think
are real in promoting a strong community
what does i think that tools do matter
it was an obvious evidence of how github
in the existence of this tool that
allowed social cooperation around coding
dramatically increased number of
contributors because at the core at the
core of the pie to the community our
projects you know people and behind
these projects are people people who
have sacrificed a lot of time a lot of
effort to build them it is didn't have
my magic West McKinney spin in a mint
tremendous amount of time pulling
together pandas John Hunter a tremendous
amount of time not with his family with
not with his job writing matplotlib
Fernando Perez been a tremendous amount
of time creating ipython it takes a lot
of effort psychiat learned we have
people here who understand that
specifically it's been a lot of time
andreas muller guile Olivia grisel a lot
of time takes effort to do this so how
do we increase the ability for people to
spend that time and collaborate and
cooperate I think tools matter so it's
one of the things we do a continuum is
actually try
create tools things like Conda things
like Vince star things that help people
organize together and distribute
software together but at the heart of
any community building activity there is
one problem and that is the problem of
human relations the problem of people
problem of our foibles our problems our
inability to get along with each other
and it does take effort to sort of
overcome some of those natural
inclinations we have to be self-centered
to kind of look at ourselves only and
kind of grab to gravitate things
ourselves and reach outward instead I
really support and admire the psf that
has come up with an actual code of
conduct it's fantastic they have this
this written statement it's fairly
generic but you look at it it's pretty
simple principles that really try to
encode in words how we treat each other
because at the heart of it that's what's
going to create a community that's the
seeds in his vibrant is how do people
treat each other and how do people react
to that community they just come and
take or do they give back so open
consider it respectful I invite you to
read that in a split in its entirety I
think it's very encouraging and
thought-provoking at the bottom overall
we're good to each other we contribute
the community not because we have to
because you want to if you remember that
these guidelines will come naturally and
I really agree with that and I kind of
want to expand on that just a little bit
with what I consider to be the basic
principles of growing a community and
this is certainly not an inclusive list
it's basically a set that I think and I
think I actually I finished my set I'd
love to get a few ideas from the
audience if you have ideas about what
are four core principle principles that
actually govern and and help a community
to grow so filia is this Greek word you
can see many of you know Greek I can
barely read it cuz I'm a mathematician
filia is this idea from Aristotle of
brotherly love is sort of several words
for love and and brotherly love is the
idea that fellowship should exist she
remembers the same community the central
idea from John Cooper interpreting some
of the writings of Aristotle is that
doing well for its own sake not by doing
it for your sake we're doing things for
mutual well being for the benefit of
others it's about reaching filia and i
think that the degree that this field
feeling filia exists in a community the
stronger it is and agree it doesn't the
less strong it is and he goes on to talk
about different
kinds of friendships that exist for
instance utility French such a pleasure
friendships of of good and really trying
to get to the friendship of good is I
think the goal another great concept
comes from the Sanskrit Sevah or say wow
this is in the Indian cultures have this
notion of selfless sacrifice
volunteering for the community and rom
das who is a member of a foundation that
kind of used this as core principle
talks about helping out it's not some
special skill it's not some rare
individual thing that people do it
really is just heating that call that
natural impulse really because we do
like to come together as communities
it's you know while we talk about the
human foibles that lead to disruption of
communities it's also human nature to
want to become part of a human community
and it gives you a tremendous joy and
satisfaction to give it definitely does
and I recommend it and that and it has
to be given from a space of I don't I'm
not looking for myself I'm not looking
for something that you return I'm just
giving because I know it's better and
because I know it can benefit the world
so and I see that it's wonderful to see
I pie de de Berlin all the volunteers
have come out together you know really
just for the goal of giving they've come
to help and support i see that the pike
on your a python we just had a lot they
had a stage full of 30 people and then a
slide full of about 60 more and you
realize that that is really an important
spirit and its partner it's important to
contemplate because it is very real now
this might be a little controversial but
i'll talk a little about a lot of
communities in the past have organized
this concept of tithes right what is
this idea type how do you support a
community that needs to exist well it
does take funds so that's the concept of
actually giving back to the community
ten percent five percent I'm not going
to argue a number it's just the concept
if every now if every company for
example uses a numpy stack actually gave
ten percent of their proceeds even those
profits that were derived directly from
the non poker stock if they gave that
back and um focus we'd have no
sustainability problem there'd be no
sustainability problem at all the truth
is they don't and you know I understand
why I understand that but if it think
about that next time you're benefiting
next time maybe you're you
are seen an opportunity for your company
to give look for a chance to give and
this brings us to one of the issues I
think that does exist it's the free
rider problem this is a real issue and
for 20 years in the community I can
definitely see it I've seen a lot of
people who just kind of come and they
just take they just come and they take
the advantage of kind of everything
that's happening and they just there's
sort of a very one-sided balance here a
lot of people who have given their a lot
of time and energy to create and a lot
of people just don't give back somehow
so that's a real issue it's not new it's
called the free rider problem it's a
reason of markets work and utopian
societies haven't in the past is that
fundamental issue of how do we exchange
and then keep make sure people are
staying at st. aware i do believe that
it by individual effort a difference can
be made if people just identify and ask
themselves how do i increase my desire
to give it can things can definitely
benefit so I'd actually like to talk and
and offer the microphone back to people
that kind of ask I have a few ideas for
solutions maybe i'll give them to get
your thinking but this isn't obviously
not a complete list we're not going to
solve the free rider problem it's a it's
a fundamental issue of human
organizations but what are ways that we
can improve it what are the ways that we
can actually encourage people to give
back I mean somebody is I have there are
certainly companies out there they're
supporting organizations out there that
are supporting the software buy products
from them you can buy services from them
you can donate to numb focus that's an
easy way you can be a company that
contributes to PI data give your have
your developers and encourage them to
produce open-source software you can
work for a company that's driving and
contributing to PI data efforts or
larger Python efforts there is a
shortage there's a shortage of talent
out there so where you work does make a
difference in kind of encouraging a
certain style is sort of a certain
workflow who's got the microphone I'd
actually like to hear from a few people
if you have a thought about this you
know these can be somewhat controversial
issues and I'd rather have a discussion
as opposed to a lecture anybody have
ideas and willing to take a microphone
and it was scary topic
we got one of the back there I perhaps
one idea might be too perhaps continuum
analytics can have a directory of
consultants and be like hub for
consultancy and then any revenue you get
you you can give some of it back to numb
focus and the rest to the consultant I
think it's tremendous idea actually
that's a really good idea kind of
basically a network of networks
individuals who are trying to contribute
back in them focus it's actually one the
reason I Pogues exist and I think just
having a place people go and say who are
the consultants it actually drives some
of the revenue back to none focus that'd
be great yeah that's a tinge that's a
great idea interesting any other
thoughts ya ever hear em some of you
heard me yesterday I think I answered
the question why people switch to
tighten from MATLAB yeah I'm such a guy
I use pythons two years now and I am or
was an matlab kya and that came from the
University because the mass works have a
lot of people they are just there to go
to the universities and cell volume
license says to the university's so
maybe you you guys can send out some
patent guys to the universities and sell
your product yeah for free because it's
free yeah but I dry my tears one euro
per used license per year multiplied
with all universities switching from
know that more details we are euros
matlab licenses to veer puddle that's
the basic income for the community and i
think the most problems solved with the
students on universities for basic we
start to program now
with you guys and can solve way better
with patents off so maybe you so
basically a low-cost entry point that
people can still pay and have that money
go to numb focus or go towards the
community efforts there happening
something like that and go to the
management of a university yeah and say
okay you pay 20,000 euros a year for
your matlab blazer right we sell it 40
yeah but you can dry our tears by
spending 200 euros or right right a
small amount of money they save money
but you guys get money from the
universities and the universities are
switching from matlab to patent and you
got a basic income and the universities
can solve the problems the same way yeah
i think i think you know outreach
getting more people involved finding
finding some transaction that's
certainly been at the heart of what i've
actually got involved in terested
economics as a graduate student as I as
I saw the benefit and really love the
open source movement but I thought how
we're going to solve the problem of
people just taking and not giving back
stuff and figured that out but I think I
think it's going to take a lot of time
and it's a lot of people doing exactly
what you described I think it's a great
a great idea and a great suggestion it
does take effort to kind of go out how
those conversations build the
organization I think others can do that
as well and I'm just sort of I guess
encouraging those who do that to kind of
come back numb focus was created for
exactly that purpose to be a place where
that organism that that that
centralization can happen there is this
this strange fear of companies in some
people's minds I think I don't know
where it comes from exactly perhaps
because we've all been mental mistreated
perhaps by a company or two but once I
started representing continuum some
there's been some weight what's your
catch what's going on are you doing this
because of some other reason and there
are other constraints the company
definitely about shareholders you've got
they have a need you haven't you have to
stay in existence so there are their
needs and that's for sure and I think I
think it's appropriate to see a company
in a slightly different light on the
other hand the people that are part of
the company are the same people that are
part of that they do exactly the things
they were doing in the past and I can
tell you as CEO of continuum our whole
goal is going to figure out how do we
fund this how do we get this how do we
get money to drive towards these efforts
they continue so they're sustainable so
we can employ people
working on free software I know others
are also doing that inria has been able
to do that Microsoft Google Facebook
they've also been able to do that hire
people and have them work on free
software I think that's a wonderful
that's a wonderful thing if you're in a
position of the company to hire someone
to work on free software that's
fantastic way to contribute so thank you
any will move on I think there's a lot
of things we could talk about there but
I think there's other issues there are
other issues that's throwing out Oh
James go ahead if you want to you want
to comment so I wanted to make a couple
of comments I'm often interacting with
companies in order to support a
community that I run most recently we
put on we've decided to do a Python
conference in August and there's been a
lot of very direct contact with
companies trying to run that conferences
tend to be very difficult and expensive
propositions and it's a testament to the
hard work of Lea and um focus that I
believe this is the seventh proper PI
data conference in the fifth city in the
world so it's been an amazing thing to
see pi doubt it succeed like this but
it's a lot of work and the operative
theory for how you reach out to a
company to get them to support an event
like this is that you say are you hiring
or do you need to market to users and
the thought is if they're hiring the
overhead cost of using recruiter are so
high that they can come to a conference
and directly interact with developers
and they can hire that way or the cost
of doing marketing and other means or
very high so they can come to a
conference and market to users directly
however I've always found these
motivations somewhat lacking I thought
that it's of course very difficult to
motivate a company to give back to the
community just because that's the right
thing to do but i think that there's
more to it than just saying are you
hiring or not i recently contacted a
company a very big company that you
probably all heard about to help support
this conference that I'm run and they
said we're not hiring Python programmers
right now we only have Java Rex open and
I thought this is a little bit
short-sighted because who here in the
audience wants to work for a company
that supports the community who here
would decide I'm working at a company
right now and I see them supporting the
community and that's the reason I want
to stay here that's a reason why I feel
like this company is doing something to
support the environment of which I live
this is a company that shares my my
principles it shares my vision it shares
it shares my values
additionally I think that a stronger
motivation is especially in areas that
are not dense conglomerations of
technical talent there is a need to
build and sustain a technical unity and
if a company does not invest today in a
community they may find in 10 or 15
years when they are China hiring or when
they are trying to launch a or the
trying to spin off or launch a new
product there may not be anybody there
who had our skills that they need you
know it's great point James I appreciate
it thanks for that commentary definitely
had some experience there I appreciate
that insight so that is a resume and I
think all of us can have some aspect to
help we can encourage people to sponsor
we can encourage people to hire we can
encourage people to support the effort
and recognize that nothing happens for
free there's effort that goes on and
that effort if it's not supported will
go away or be not as productive as it
could be I have lots of stories about
how things aren't as far along as they
should be a numpy and scifi and pandas
and I Python simply because the funding
hasn't been there so that's a it's a
real issue I think another issue that
faces our community is lack of diversity
and this is the heart is a hard one it's
a cultural one I think a community
benefits from a diverse membership this
is true across biology it's across every
organization there's a reason we want to
support a diverse community because you
know like minded people think the same
and we need different thoughts and newer
thoughts out-of-the-box thinking to
really grow and expand so how do we
encourage this I don't have a lot of
answers here I I have three daughters
myself none of them seem to be
interested in computer seconds or being
a part of a community like this is by my
best efforts come on sweetie let's go
code together somehow
somehow that just didn't didn't didn't
take off with any of them their patient
okay daddy so I know that sometimes it's
just not it's just not part of some
people's makeup maybe there's things I
could occur done earlier I don't know
but there are people that want to code
there are women and other minorities who
want to code how do we encourage them
I'd like to hear from a few people in
the audience actually and that's
restricted to women if we could do to
give us an answer or other minorities as
well right hi I'm I I slightly object to
how he said um that some people don't
have the makeup like your daughter's
maybe i dinnae I spend most of my life
not programming I've got a PhD in
mathematics I started coding while doing
my PhD I actually got quite fine to
mathematics without ever coding and I
always thought I didn't want to code um
with all I really giving it a go so I
would have said most of my life that
well yeah I wasn't into coding at all
and it turns out that I'm a fairly
passionate and talented rumor so I kind
of stumbled into it and it's pure luck
or coincidence or whatever that I'm
actually here and I guess there are many
people out there who robbed and then
they see people play doom or whatever
and say I don't want to be part of their
community feels wrong and yeah it's
there are stereotypes out there and we
need to break down these stereotypes and
part of that is actually making it I
think easier for people like me to
actually walk into them like this and
I'll feel like it I can animal in the
zoo a little bit right and sorry this is
very personal I've never talked about
this really you know I did expert 84
it's not as if this is not new this is
really important and some of the things
that happen for example some people have
extremely condescending I've been asked
if I actually went to a talk by accident
oh boy um
was talkin graph databases and graph
databases get you stood up in what are
they called dating websites apparently
and the person thought I was there
because I misunderstood the title
somehow yeah you get all sorts of
condescending reactions people ask you
what language you use when it's a c++
they are really surprised um and I think
as long as we don't stop judging people
by I don't know what they look like
what's obviously on the cover we're not
going to get there yeah I appreciate
that I think that's really really
important so what you're saying is
there's hope for my daughters I'll keep
it thank you maybe you can make an
invite you over to my place you can read
me meet them encourage shooting involved
with they can choose what they want to
do that I've had to want to force
something on them nonetheless I think
that's very important you said a lot of
really important things people shouldn't
feel alone we battle we stereotype
because it's it's a protective mechanism
all of us do it we have to its way our
brains work and the challenge is making
sure that that natural instinct to
stereotype to make sense of a complex
world that we can't possibly comprehend
without categorizing that that need to
do that does not overwhelm the need to
put it down we also have frontal lobe
that can stop it so that's the great
thing we have we can we have a villa to
model other situations and to stop some
of those natural inclinations so it does
take effort and we need to do it and
recognize we have that tendency is I
think absolutely that's correct is
somebody who comes a minority or other
underrepresented person who comes to a
community if they feel alone they're not
going to come back it's gonna be very
difficult for them to come back and so
you have to be almost you have to over
welcome in many cases thank you that was
an excellent commentary we have time for
one more anybody else will have insight
they want to share some day we'll do
brain research and we'll be able to
understand how to fix ourselves and the
problems that we create I'm hopeful
actually go ahead
taking out both people who themselves of
they think they can I t because chlorine
actuated experiment rather point and she
studied political science and a teacher
of you formally as well basically
example technical team to go and stop
eating people I said it can't go there
telligent take you all programming tell
them because they all fake is like magic
that's fantastic actually and that is
one way every one of us who are here can
contribute to the community is by going
out and mentoring helping doing that
bringing somebody else up to the Toto to
exposing the things we're excited about
because that is a one on one
relationship and it's very individual
and it makes a huge difference so that
is absolutely that's great I appreciate
that actually covers a couple of things
well the last issues I'm not going to
spend much time on this but I think it's
real is there are bad actors that will
emerge in any community I mean it's the
reason we have prisons the reason we
have you know courts and that sort of
thing fortunately in a community like
ours the voluntary Association some of
these issues are dealt with pretty
simply because it sort of sort of just a
route around it but there are going to
be people who don't follow the psf code
of conduct who are growing difficult
make it difficult to track diversity
you're going to make bad comments they
maybe they're just going to come and
leach in the community and say oh that's
great I'm go there and then hire a bunch
of people and not do anything except you
know just use that community as a
feeding ground for my own needs that's
going to happen how do we deal with that
I guess and I think this is a it needs
filia I mean Sevah and means basically
people who are not stereotyping and
trying to fight that that desire to
stereotype I think one important
principle is patience recognizing that
your view
it's it is a view I mean it that person
may not be a bad actor you know the idea
of something being a bad actor I put it
in quotes because I go they exist but
the first time I think it needs a few
people to agree that they exist because
we all have our perceptions we're all we
get we get feelings hurt we get things
you know we step on each other's toes
and it's easy to see someone is a bad
actor when they're not maybe just a
misunderstanding happened so I think you
know along with patients comes
forgiveness becomes acceptance becomes
allowing people to change encouraging
that change sometimes you're going to
have to route around some people and you
have to speak up and defend when
necessary but listen and give other
points of view as well because it's very
likely that your perspective is not
complete and then ultimately you can
route around the troublemakers and I
think that the idea that this too shall
pass is a reasonable concept and not
getting too worked up sometimes and
having a little more a little patience
and supporting positive activities right
that's one of the tenants one of the
reasons the bad actors can destroy a
community is because they focus
attention on that event rather than
focusing attention on the good that the
community is doing and sometimes one way
to respond to a bad actor it's just
simply to increase the level of positive
giving giving that you're doing so I'm
not an expert there's a lot of people
have a lot more recommendations I know
how much time we have actually are we am
I supposed to end at 115 or 130 115
we're out of time okay so you can
definitely write about these issues I
know there's some things my summary is
that python has a long and fruitful
history in data analytics and science it
will continue to have a long and bright
future with your help but so contribute
to the Pied of the community make the
world a better place in our little
corner of it it's not the only way to
make the world a better place but it is
a way to make the world a better place
we have one comment in yes
I meet other columns we would be fine
ladies group traffic should we improve I
must buy a mist around low priority get
diversity I'm anna-lysa lyrics forming
around other areas at when contacted
nicely from the roof perfect rain I
think thank you again that's great point
pi ladies is a phenomenal organization
they're doing great work for the Python
community and as we project on the pike
if I the community we can benefit from
the pie ladies world as well so here's
some brief community commercials things
you can do today and with that I'll
leave you to the rest of the conference
thank you
good